[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue je suis Jean-Baptiste
Lavergne Morazzani du restaurant La
Table du 11 à Versailles on a également
le Bistrot du 11 et la cave du 11 et
aujourd'hui on va faire une recette
autour du topinambour et de l'infirmier
[Musique]
on va cuire assez simplement
moitié eau moitié lait
[Musique]
c'est des oignons rôtis qu'on vient
mouiller à l'eau et on laisse cuire le
jus pendant au moins deux jours
[Musique]
on va transformer en huile donc là on va
passer par le froid par la congélation
pour avoir vraiment le côté très vert on
le congèle avec l'huile de pépin de
raisin une fois que les feuilles sont
blanchies ensuite on vient de mixer et
du coup on a une huile qui est très
verte parce que c'est bloqué par le
froid ensuite on va commencer notre
topping
donc on va commencer par Lacazette donc
on est sur une noisette bio de Bourgogne
[Musique]
donc on vient griller et ensuite réduit
en poudre hachez très fin donc là l'idée
c'est vraiment d'apporter des textures à
notre plat on a quelque chose d'assez
crémeux d'assez lisse là on va porter du
topping sur le dessus pour avoir un côté
un petit peu plus croustillant
donc on vient caraméliser ensuite on les
égoutte on les met sur papier on les
déshydrate
[Musique]
pareil on vient déshydrater de
l'estragon frais un très court moment au
four on va laisser pendant 6 minutes à
160 degrés donc pour garder la couleur
très verte
[Musique]
on vient le confire à basse température
à 70 degrés dans une huile d'olive Corse
de l'altaro donc le sud de la Corse on
va venir le déposer tout doucement tout
délicatement sur le haut de l'assiette
et voici le topinambour avec l'œuf
fermier donc la petite astuce que j'ai à
vous donner c'est pour avoir une nuit de
Prévert de basilic c'est de passer par
la congélation donc n'oubliez pas de
blanchir vos feuilles de Basil ensuite
vous les mouiller à hauteur avec l'huile
de pépins de raisin c'est l'huile qui
captera le plus de goût et seulement le
lendemain une fois que cette huile est
réserve son congelées vous mixez et vous
passez dans un chinois étamine je vous
souhaite bon appétit
[Musique]